so why is this happening
well it's incredibly frustrating for
londoners today businesses and commuters
the rmc are concerned about some of the
conditions the government may attach to
a funding deal that tfo needs because of
the
pandemic i'm concerned
the government's almost deliberately
provoking industrial action in london
like it's seen across the country what's
really important though is that the
trade unions businesses and londoners
with me
lobby the government to make sure
any deal they do with tfl doesn't have
conditions attached that damages our
recovery and i'm asking the rmt to work
with me so we can lobby the government
for a deal without draconian conditions
i think back in 2016 you promised that
there'd be zero strikes in the capital
uh it may not be an official pledge but
but you did did say it and yet there's
been almost 100 public transport strikes
in your time as mayor of london
i'm quite clear i don't resile
from saying all strikes are a sign of
failure and the aspiration should be for
zero strikes and before the pandemic
we'd managed to reduce the number of
strikes in london since i became mayor
by more than 70 so more than 70 by
working
with trade unions at the same time we
reduced our deficit by more than a
billion pounds by more than 71 increased
cash balances and had a fantastic public
transport in london and it still is the
only reason
for these strikes in recent weeks in
london is because of the conditions the
government is trying to attach to a
funding deal and the trade unions are
concerned about the consequences of
those conditions on their uh members is
about pension concerns that trade unions
have i don't want these conditions
imposed on our trans workers our transit
workers have been heroes for the last
two and a half years keeping public
transport running in london to allow our
key workers like nurses doctors teachers
retailers police officers to get to work
the way to reward them is not by having
draconian conditions that changes their
pensions unilaterally
so do you support their strikes
well i don't support strikes i think
strikes are a sign of failure generally
speaking but it's important to
understand and have empathy with why
trans workers are frustrated and worried
as i speak to you there are more than
100 bereaved families of transfer
workers maybe watching
this
how do you think they feel that the
response from the government is to try
and unilaterally impose conditions on a
deal we only need the deal because of
the pandemic the government's given
long-term deals to many others who
needed support during the pandemic what
i'm saying to the government in a
respectful way is you don't get a
national recovery without a london
recovery you don't get 11 recovery
without tfl final cylinders and they
shouldn't be punishing hard-working
transport workers
i'm a little bit confused about where
you stand then you got real sympathy for
the the rail workers you talked about
them being being heroes but you don't
support the strikes is that right
i don't support today's strikes in
london the reason why the rmt is
striking today in london are their
concerns about the government
unilaterally changing their terms and
conditions i don't want that to happen
the true unit doesn't happen but strikes
isn't the answer today the answer today
is the trade unions working with me and
others businesses londoners to lobby the
government for a decent deal caught in
the crossfire today is not the
government or grant shops it's commuters
it's businesses it's people who need the
tubes to get to the place of work or to
get to an appointment and that's why
it's really important to understand
that we're on the same side here whether
you're a business who needs tfl final
cylinders whether you're a commuter who
needs to use the tubes today whether
you're a transfer workers uh or the
transport workers who wants to make sure
that terms aren't unilaterally changed
can i turn to to the issue of crime in
the capital and uh
the recent state of knife crimes have
been six homicides in the capital in
less than a week why is this still
happening
well it's very important this
conversation because they may be
watching uh to send my condolences to
the family and friends of those six
people who've lost their lives in london
they're all different uh so you can't
give one
answer to these six disparate uh awful
awful uh cases the police have made
arrests and charges in in in five of
them we have seen uh and it's no
consolation of the victims of crime or
brief families a reduction in gun crime
knife crime knife injury knife injury of
those blind age 25 in the last year
we've seen a reduction of more than 68
in teenage homicides but we are seeing
uh this summer what we see i'm afraid in
previous summers which is an increase in
violent crime the police are working
incredibly hard with the limited
resources they have they've seen police
officer cuts over the last 12 13 years
21 000 officers cut over the last 12
years the governments are going to
replace them with 20 000 offices but in
london we ask for 6 000 we've only been
given 4
300 but we are from city hall supporting
our police with 1300 more officers at
the same time we're supporting
communities giving young people
constructive things to do particularly
during the summer holidays when schools
return after schools at weekends because
we're going to make sure we deal with
the causes of crime as well as crime
itself
well yes i'm sure a lot of people hear
your call for more police officers but
but you talk about
this happening in the summer you talk
about the need for more occupation for
young people during school holidays and
they they may
think that you're blaming the weather
for the rise in violence is that what
you're
suggesting
what i'm saying is if you look back in
previous summers in august with school
holidays
uh with the other issues that we face
with a cost-living crisis without
excusing criminality we know there are
complex causes deprivation inequality
lack opportunities those have been
exacerbated by the pandemic but also by
the cost of living crisis and before the
summer days began the police myself and
others did you know explain to londoners
and others we were concerned about an
increase in violence this summer that's
why we're investing in record sums in
keeping young people busy this uh summer
more than 2 500 schemes this summer for
young people to be doing to keep them
busy thankfully we've not seen the
teenage homicides or the teenage
violence we've seen in previous summers
i'm afraid though we have seen the last
week six families bereave suffering
bereavements uh tragedies because of
these awful awful uh homicides we can't
pretend
uh that cuts haven't got consequences
and one of the consequences of cuts in
our police cuts in our public services
youth clubs youth workers youth services
has been since 2013 an increase in
serious youth violence
well yes and you say um
awful for the families who are caught up
with this but also people who live in
those areas
quite frightened
by those situations what would you say
to reassure people who are worried about
their safety
i i fully understand
people's fear of crime perception is how
they feel and they feel scared that's
why it's really important that what the
police have done is to make sure they're
freeing up
resources to have high visibility
policing uh on top of the neighborhood
teams on top of the violent suppression
units on top of the violent crime task
force we're funding from
city hall but let's not pretend
we have the number of police officers we
need in our capital city we are a
capital city with all the complexities
that brings that's why it's really
important whether it's list trust or
rishi
uh they give us the police officers
we've been asking for the police and
myself which is six thousand additional
offices another four thousand three
hundred we've been given we're grateful
for the four thousand three hundred
we've not had those in in the in the
last few years while i've been there
they're coming out but we need the full
6 000 rather than 4 300.